mais mes chers
collègues
notre notre séance est commune aux deux
commissions est
ouverte monsieur le Président de la
Commission de la
Défense vous aviez pris
l'initiative
d'inviter monsieur Vedrine et d'ailleurs
monsieur de Villepin
à intervenir sur un sujet très
intéressant qui était l'Afrique après le
engagement militaire ce qui était très
intéressant c'est à quoi je vous ai
répondu que l'Afrique après le
désengagement militaire c'était
évidemment les affaires
étrangères ce qui paraît aller de soi en
en terme donc je suis très heureux que
nous puissions faire parce que le
désengagement militaire en Afrique c'est
très important et que nous puissions
recevoir deux alors nous allons recevoir
uniquement monsieur Vedrine aujourd'hui
donc il y avait au départ une puissance
invitante qui était monsieur le
président cassiliou et deux invités qui
étaient monsieur Vedrine et et monsieur
de Villepin et nous avons transformé ça
en deux puissances invitantes qui sont
les deux présidents des commissions des
affaires de La Défense et des Affaires
étrangères et un seul invité pour
l'instant mais la qualité et et là c'est
celle c'est Monsieur Vedrine monsieur de
Villepin nous ayant fait savoir qu'il
était tout à fait prêt à à venir en sans
doute au mois de janvier pour prolonger
l'entretien mais comme me dit le
monsieur
les idées de Monsieur vilpa je les
connais assez bien je pourrais les
expliquer aussi et c'est vrai qu'on a
distingué un certain nombre de
convergence entre entre entre ces deux
éminents représentants de la diplomatie
historique de la diplomatie française et
d'ailleurs certains membres de cette
commission dont je dois dire comme vous
le vous l'avez remarqué monsieur
monsieur le ministre
comme le président de la commission des
affaires étrangères donc c'est un un un
grand un grand bonheur pour nous deux de
vous recevoir euh vous chacun vous
connaît je rappellerai vous êtes ancien
secrétaire général de la présidence de
la République auprès de François
mitteran ancien ministre des Affaires
étrangères de
1997 à 2012 et nous sommes évidemment
très heureux euh d'accueillir euh de de
d'entendre votre analyse sur la
politique africaine de la France alors
évidemment j'ai cru comprendre que
comme diraient les évêques en d'autres
circonstances d'autres enjeux nous
sollicitent que ceux de l'Afrique et
peut-être
serez-vous heureux de de nous faire part
au gré des questions qui vous seront
posées ou spontanément d'un certain
nombre d'analyses sur des situations sur
la situation
particulièrement urgente et tragique que
nous connaissons au au Moyen-Orient
alors je vous souhaite donc la
bienvenue
nous nous nous
allons je je pense que sur
l'Afrique je vais laisser la parole
évidemment à au président cassillou dans
un tout dans un court instant sur
l'Afrique nous sommes effectivement
confrontés nous avons eu un grand débat
à la sur un rapport qui avait été fait
par Madame Tabarot et par Monsieur fou
sur la politique africaine et ce rapport
appelé effectivement à une révision
assez en profondeur
de notre politique africaine de son côté
la commission de la défense sous
l'autorité du président cassiliou a mené
tout un cycle de réflexion très
intéressant sur un certain nombre
d'aspects relatifs à au lien entre la
politique de défense et la politique
africaine donc nous nous allons faire
converger nos questionnements nos
analyses nous n'allons pas je vais pas
parler trop longtemps parce que nous
n'avons pas énormément de temps mais je
crois que nous nous nous serons très
heureux de savoir effectivement si
comment vous percevez les nouveaux défis
la nouvelle approche de la politique
africaine de la France et peut-être un
certain nombre de de focus comme on dit
de points particulierers hier soir
monsieur Lecoq avait organisé avec un
une excellente une excellente projection
un ex la projection d'un excellent film
est terriblement terriblement terrible à
regarder sur les guerres des dernières
années en République démocratique du
Congo c'était un un film saisissant je
pense que sur cette question vous avez
beaucoupes beaucoup intervenu sur le
Rwanda sur cette question de la RDC vous
aurez certainement quelque chose à dire
de très particul de très intéressant et
je pense que nous nous vous écouterons
et puis après sans doute vous aurez je
pense que nos collègues vous
solliciteront un peu sur le Moyen-Orient
et vous nous adressereai vos analyses
maintenant je vais laisser la parole au
au président cassiliou où ensuite vous
intervenez nos usages hein ce sont bien
les mêmes c'est une intervention
liminaire de la durée que le notre
invité souhaite entre 10 et 20 minutes
et puis ensuite des questions rapides
posées par les représentants des groupes
et vous répondez chaque fois à chaque
représentant pour donner une allure
assez vivante à ces échanges monsieur le
président la commission de défense je
vous donne bien volontiers la parole en
tant que co-président de cette réunion
merci Monsieur le
président de la commission des des
Affaires étrangères pour pour cette
audition commune monsieur le le ministre
mes chers collègues euh merci à nouveau
monsieur le Président d'avoir accepté le
le principe de cette audition commune
qui pour la commission de la défense
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un cycle que
nous menons actuellement sur la
politique africaine de la France sous sa
dimension sécuritaire et nous sortons à
l'instant d'une audition de de fingtank
à ce sujet et nous avons dans le cadre
de ce cyle proposé à d'autres
commissions de de s'associer à nos
travaux dans une approche dans un
premier temps qui sera
multidimensionnelle avant de de retomber
sur un sujet purement sécuritaire et par
exemple hier nous avons mené une
audition commune avec la commission du
développement durable et l'aménagement
du territoire sur les impacts
sécuritaires du du dérèglement et la
commission des affaires étrangères bien
entendu sur les impacts sécuritaires du
du dérèglement climatique alors
effectivement l'opération barce est
terminé pour autant ne signifie pas pour
autant la fin de la présence militaire
française en Afrique vous savez que nous
y servons de nombreux de nombreuses
forces prépositionnées que ce soit à
Dakar à Djibouti à njamena à
Abidjan avec les éléments français au
gabron pour en citer quelques-unes que
par ailleurs nous avons une coopération
militaire avec de de nombreux pays et
que par ailleurs nous aurons
potentiellement dans les années qui
arrivent des opérations à à y mener ça
fait plusieurs foes dans notre histoire
on dit que on on a plus d'opération mené
en Afrique malheureusement l'actualité
nous rappelle parfois à certaines de de
nos responsabilités
moi il me semble de deux points que deux
points pour être évoqués aujourd'hui
pour valoriser votre présence monsieur
le le ministre d'une part une question
qu'on se pose pas assez à mon sens c'est
la question souvent du pourquoi pourquoi
notre politique africaine que
que quels y sont réellement nos intérêts
et d'ailleurs on voit parfois une
décorrélation entre l'énergie qu'on y
met et les intérêts réels qu'on peut
avoir dans tel ou tel pays intérêt
sécuritaire intérêt économique intérêt
d'influence ou intérêt plus globaux
notamment par exemple dans la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique et
puis au-delà du pourquoi bien entendu la
question qui nous intéresse c'est la
question du comment d'un point de vue
mul multidimensionnel et c'est pourquoi
ce travail commun que nous avons
ensemble euh qui j'espère est est le
démarrage du nouvelle air de coopération
ent de nos deux commissions euh est
intéressant pour avoir cette approche
globale et je sais que monsieur le
ministre vous avez souvent l'habitude de
dire que les grands discours ne marchent
plus euh et en conséquence j'aimerais
vous poser la question question
finalement de comment quelle nouvelle
coopération vous envisagez entre la
France et l'Afrique j'allais dire bien
entendu vu de ma fenêtre au-delà des
coopérations sécuritaires mais voilà
notre temps esté je reste là monsieur le
Président un mot pour d'organisation
entre nous je vais donner la parole au
groupe et puis tu donneras la
parole aux orateurs particuliers on fait
comme ça ça va très bien monsieur
monsieur le ministre c'est à
vous
c'est
bon et bien d'abord je remercie les les
présidents les deux présidents de
m'avoir invité à venir devant vous ça
m'est déjà arrivé plusieurs fois depuis
que je ne suis plus ministre il y a très
longtemps c'est toujours un contact très
très intéressant très précieux stimulant
c'est un peu une pression parce que j'ai
pas les j'ai une réflexion on va dire
historique dans la durée mais j'ai pas
forcément des tas d'éléments absolument
à jour enfin je suis content d'être là
j'aurais été très content de le faire
avec Dominique Villepin je suis dire
venu à votre invitation avecin Jupé je
crois oui oui et enfin bon c'était une
plaisanterie je suis d'accord avec une
partie de ce que dit Dominique de
Villepin et qui s'exlique parce qu'il
dit lui-même souvent qu'il est un homme
du Sud un homme du Sud né au Maroc élevé
au Venezuela en poste très tô en Inde et
et donc il a une sensibilité qui
n'efface pas les autres la mienne la
vôtre mais il a des des tas d'antennes
dans ce qu'on appelle le chut global qui
n d'ailleurs pas global qui a étéoclite
enfin qui a beaucoup de qui pèse dans le
débat y compris l'affaire de l'avenir de
l'Afrique puisque toutes les puissances
au monde on nonont pas une politique
africaine mais une politique en Afrique
pas dans toute l'Afrique il y a
quasiment personne qui une politique
dans toute l'Afrique il a plus de 50
pays bon alors je pense qu'il faut
distinguer pour réfléchir sur tout ça
l'histoire que je veux pas développer
par qu'on n pas devant une académie
historique il arrive à des assemblées
doter des lois mémoriales à mon avis
c'est une sautise enfin bon c'est un
mélange de Gen en tout cas mais en tout
cas il y a l'histoire et mon avis en
résumé c'est que plus personne en France
en Europe ne connaît l'histoire longue
de l'Afrique il y a presque plus aucun
spécialiste de ce qui était l'Afrique
avant les colonisations la colonisation
est très peu connue parce qu'elle est
abordé que sous l'ongle moral c'est
c'est mal donc tout est mal donc il y a
pas d'analyse et alors qu'elles sont
très différentes c'est pas les mêmes
selon les pays en a qui ont été à tross
et sanglantes donc qui sont passé
facilement bon et cetera euh et donc on
les on les connaît pas on mélange tout
les décolonisations sont peu connues en
fait maintenant la première époque des
décolonisations sont mal connu l'époque
dans lequel fouette boignier invente la
francearique c'est pas la France qui a
inventé la France-Afrique c'est la
demande de sangorde ou fouette et cetera
ceux qui avaient demandé au général de
Gaulle de maintenir des bases en disant
si l'armée française ne reste pas on va
être obligé de faire des armées nous et
ils vont faire des pches et ça va coûter
cher et cetera bon donc a toute une
période des décolonisations réussies
réussie si vous reportez à la disons aux
écrits même au médias de l'époque
notamment en Afrique il y a une période
qui est très optimiste on formidable s
est pas bien sorti partout je parle pas
de l'Algérie he là je parle de l'Afrique
bon donc a des périodes très mal connues
et la politique française en Afrique
qu'il faudrait analyser en différenciant
quand même ce qui s'est passé sous les
différents présidents avec des
évolutions permanentes notamment la
césure du discours de la boule de
François mitteran qui à un moment donné
constate que l'URS est sur sa fin et que
donc les régimes africains qui on disait
faudit quand même réprimer un peu moins
sortir des garts de prison et cetera il
dis faut m'emmerder trop on va faire une
alliance avec l'URS bon à un moment
donné ils peuvent plus donc on se dit
c'est le moment d'avancer d'où
l'arbitrage du discours de la Baule avec
une phrase clé dans un discours par
ailleurs interminable qui était de dire
on va laisser tomber personne mais on va
aider plus favorablement les pays qui
vont avancer vers la la démocratie avec
un débat encore maintenant sur quels ont
été les effets il y a des il y a des
pays d'Afrique dans lesquels les
minoritaires se sont dit si on prend pas
le pouvoir tout de suite on est fait CHU
donc il y a des effets complètement
paradoxaux tout à fait oubliés mais en
moyenne il y a eu des élections des
constitutions des ceci des cela donc il
a une césure je dis pas ça parce que je
travaille avec mit il y a vraiment une
césure historique par rapport à ça il
faudrait reconstituer toutes les
évolutions en rappelant que la fameuse
France-Afrique c'est dans le
dictionnairees de Flober est annoncé on
met fin la franceafrique régulièrement
tous les ans depuis 30 ans bon c'est
complètement idiot parce queil y a plus
personne en en France qui connaissent
bien l'Afrique peut-être vous il y a
peut-être ici 10 des seuls spécialistes
de l'Afrique les journalistes
connaissent
pas les anthropologues il y en a plus
donc la connaissance des Afriques moi je
tout le temps en France c'est effondré
les Africains les dirigeants africains
pour qui c'est quand même très très
important de savoir ce que ce qui se
décide à Paris ou à Bruxelles ou
ailleurs sont plus aguéris en réalité
mais dans lere sens non donc il y a plus
de France-Afrique au sens sociologie
d'avant les relations les liens la
connaissance le terrain quelques hommes
d'affaires mais quelques grands chefs
d'entreprise mais ils ont une
connaissance très utilitaire très
spécialisé donc a un effondrement de la
France-Afrique pas sous le au sens qu'on
donne d'habitude à cette formule qui
donc n'existe plus depuis longtemps mais
sous la forme fondement sociologique bon
mais on n'est pas dans une académie
historique dommage et tout ça n'a pas
d'intérêt pour vous maintenant mais mon
résumé à moi c'est que ce qu'on dit sur
l'Afrique aujourd'hui est uniquement
corrélé un état particulier de l'opinion
française qui est convulsé là-dessus
comme sur plein de sujets et des
opinions de quelques pays peu nombreux
en Afrique peu nombreux il y a plus de
50 pays en Afrique ils font partie du
fameux Sud global atéroclite on est dans
un moment de de discours en tout cas sur
le le monde
post-occidental la désoccidentalisation
qui touche aussi l'Afrique plus ou moins
fort ils sont évidemment pas d'accord
entre eux l'Inde et la Chine sont pas
d'accord mais voilà le bruit de fond
qu'on entend par rapport ça peut pas ne
pas toucher l'Afrique or en Afrique les
pays qui sont sortent mal qui ont mal
gouverné Obama avait dit des choses
formidables ughana dans son premier
mandat là-dessus en disant arrêtez de
raconter que vos problèmes sont liés à
l'esclavage la colonisation c'est très
ancien vous êtes indépendant depuis des
dizaines d'années et vous êtes
responsable de la situation actuelle
fallait Obama pour le culot bien bon il
au Ghana il est bien choisi c'est un
pays bien géré par ailleurs donc vous
remarquerez que le F tout le sentiment
antifrançais qu'on a l'impression de
voir c'est dans un petit nombre de pays
un petit nombre de gouvernements souvent
appuyés ou excité par des diasporas en
Europe radicalisé pour d'autres raisons
ça représente pas du tout l'Afrique pas
du tout en général et la France encore
maintenant est très bienvenue dans
presque tous les pays d'Afrique et même
dans les pays qui mettent en avant la
dénonciation de la France alors qu' a
une longue période d'après la
décolonisation c'était pas du tout la
tonalité hein même dans ces pays-là
c'est plus complexe et puis on verra
bien dans quelques années quand on quand
ils ont ils ont marre de Wagner et
compagnie voez donc je suis pour
relativiser ça et pour aborder les
questions sans aucune repentance c'est
pas justifié historiquement c'est
absurde ça sert à rien en plus et c'est
pas ce que demandent les Africains
africain de Paris peut-être électeurs
africains à Paris mais mais pas les
Africains donc je suis pour avoir une
approche historique beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus ample on va dire d'autant
que si la France était attaquée c'est
parce que ass ses bonnes filles est
resté les Belges ont laissé une
situation monstrueuse Rwanda Burundi
République démocratique du Congo
démocratique entre guillemets bon les
les les Portugais ont laissé des guerres
civile Angola Mozambique il y a plein de
guerres civiles qui ont eu lieu dans des
pays qui étai dans la colination
Britannique avant contrairement à ce
qu'on raconte mais tous ces pays ont
fiché le camp ils sont jamais restés il
y a qu'en France qui a eu à la demande
des Africains et par pour un mélange de
comment dire de même pas tellement
d'intérêt parce que ça se discute mais
d'idée que celon fait de notre rôle et
puis des un intérêt vrai pour l'Afrique
qui existé dans ces pays la Fran est
resté coopération vous rappelez de
substitution coopération de formation
tout ça a évolué donc quand vous avez à
faire un petit nombre de pays notamment
dans le Sahel
il faut dire que c'est c'est effrayant
gouverner les pays du Sahel c'est quand
même impossible bon quand ça marche pas
pour 36 raisons qui ne tiennent pas
qu'au feu qui sont mauvais et corrompus
qui sont il y a des raisons objectives
économique climatique et cetera quand il
cherchent un bouémissaire Occidental bah
c'est la France qui est là de même que
quand les au début quand il y a la
menace djihadiste sur
bamaco quand les pays les gouvernements
appellent à l'aide les pays voisins
appellent la l'IDE le Conseil de
sécurité d'accord et qu'il faut
intervenir euh il y a pas la force
d'interposition annoncée par l'Afrique
depuis 15 20 ans donc on Conseil de
sécurité on dit qu'est-ce qui peut s'en
occuper ah il y a la France il y a la
France un peu bête quoi mais qu' là et
qui fait l'opération l' a raison il
prend une décision courageuse juste et
comme heureusement on n'a pas
démentimbulé le système de décision
hérité du Z de Gaul sur ce point il
décide et ça marche tout de suite après
je crois qu'on aurait pas dû rester mais
c'est pour dire que la France est dans
une situation particulière à la fois
pour rendre service à un moment donné si
c'est vraiment demandé et que personne
d'autre n'est capable de le faire
notamment pas les Africains qui devrai
s'en occuper en réalité mais ça se
retourne et donc on est le Bou émissaire
facile donc vous laissez pas trop
impressionné par le les discours des
pchistes dans les différents pays du
Sahel qui on reviendront et il faut
avoir une vision historique plus longue
bon tout ça c'est du discours historique
alors que j'ai dit que c'était pas une
instance historique donc la vraie
question c'est maintenant on est obligé
d'être tout à fait réaliste tout à fait
réaliste la France ne peut pas rester
dans des pays qui ne souhaitent pas
qu'elle reste c'est aussi simple que ça
quel que soit le débat historique comme
je vous l'ai dit là l'approche
historique elle est fausse elle est
incomplète le moralisme ne mène à rien
et cetera on comprend rien mais on peut
pas rester pour je sais pas quelle
raison et on n' pas décidé à un moment
donné en France que notre présence
serait essentiellement terre personne n'
décidé ça il y a pas de choix français
il y a des demandes des Africains il y a
des enchaînement il y a des décisions
des engrenages mais c'est pas un choix
donc jamais la France a dit on va faire
une croix sur l'influence économique sur
l'influence culturelle sur l'influence
humaine les relations et cetera personne
n dit donc faut pas être traumatisé par
le fait qu'on soit dans un une impasse
apparente et que à la demande de régime
nul par ailleurs on puisse pas rester on
est venu à leur demande on a fait le
job ils veulent pas qu'on reste on s'en
va faudrait que ça soit pas du tout
c'est évident ce que je dis mais je suis
il faut ça doit pas être traumatisant
traumatisant on s'est bien comporté
c'est encore une fois faut penser à
l'avenir on peut pas rester dans la
situation on est le seul pays
potentiellement disponible par une sorte
d'abus de
générosité mal conçu une idée enfin une
sorte de dérive de l'idée qu'onit de
notre il remplace c'est terminé ça donc
faut revenir
réalité un jour j'étais dans l'avion de
Jacques Chirac retour de Mauritanie avec
Pierre
Mesmer pierre Mesmer voilà quelqu'un qui
connaissait l'Afrique il y a eu un
rassemblement à dans un BL de Mauritanie
où il avait commandé c'était génial il y
avait 350 chameaux c'est formidable pour
célébrer Mesmer et donc Mesmer nous dit
dans l'avion dans une vingtaine d'années
l'Afrique reviendra ce qu'elle était
avant la colonisation
c'est-à-dire en fait des pouvoirs variés
des des entités multiples certaines qui
se développent très bien d'autres pas
mais personne ne contrôle l'ensemble du
territoire c'est ça qu' voulait dire
donc il s'attendait que sa connaissance
d'africain d'avant d'avant ou le monde
d'avant avant s'attendit à ce qu'il y
ait des situations de ce genre AC
énormément de zones grisees parce qu'on
voit encore aujourd'hui je le cite pour
mémoire et simplement pour faire sourire
un instant donc principe simple
aujourd'hui que je jette dans le débat
on est intervenu qu'à leur demande on a
rougir de rien rien vous connaissez mon
assistance sur le rand on maintenant 40
livres dans le monde entier notamment en
Afrique en Angleterre au Canada aux
États-Unis qui montre qu'il a rien n'
reprocher à la France et en plus
plusieurs pression de diffamation qui
ont été gagné maintenant donc on peut
discuter mais on l'a jamais fait jusqu'à
maintenant sur est- que raison au début
en 90 quand Kagamé a déclenché la guerre
civile pour reprendre le pouvoir en tant
que minorité parce que sinon après il
aurait pas pu de bloquer en disant ça va
être atroce il y aurait les massacres de
62 on va s'interposer ce qui permettra
un compromis qui était atteint à l'été
9 13 rouchin par que les gens on
oublient parce qu'on a fait une erreur
monstrueuse à l'époque on na jamais
communiquer sur la politique menée
sintéressait personne personne le
demander on aurait dû faire un
gigantesque option d'accord bref on est
dans une
situation il faut oublier cet aspect là
enfin je plaide pour ça mais je crois
qu'il y a plein d'éléments objectifs il
n'empêche queon peut se poser des
questions sur la décision d'origine en
90 est-ce que mitthéan a eu raison à
l'époque de croire qu'on avait une
responsabilité et que comme au cowet
comme au comme au Tchad comme au malwin
il fallait empêcher des modifications de
de pouvoir et de frontièr par la force
moi je pense qu'on peut en discuter je
pense qu'il fallait pas y aller en fait
j'ai toujours dit que les attaques sur
ce qui a été fait après étaient fausses
mais je pense que c'était une erreur
avec le recul en tout cas la décision
initiale voyez je distingue les deux
mais dans le cas de Hollande je trouve
qu'il a eu raison de dire on y va la
question étant sur est-ce qu'on a raison
de rester est-ce qu'il y avait voilà
donc je reviens
conclusion pas de on va pas bâtir la
suite sur la à partir de la repentance
qui à mon avis fausse historiquement on
na pas à rougir de ce qu'on a fait li
comment en Libye en Libye c'est mélangé
parce qu'il y a la France et la
Grande-Bretagne et le soutien de l'OTAN
la résolution du Conseil de
sécurité visait interdire khadfi d'aller
baigner benazi dans des rivières de sang
comme disait le fils khadfi donc on a eu
raison au début au début par contre il y
a un engrenage après ça se transforme en
chasse à l'âme et cadfi est tué il
aurait mieux valu l'éviter il y a pas
faut pas exagérer le le rôle abusif de
bchel enfin de toute façon abusif mais
faut pas exagérer les conséquences de ça
bon en tout cas je dirais globalement
sur la base de la la haine de soi la
repentance la flagélation on va rien
bâtir les Africains ne le demandent pas
quand j'ai fait à la demande de Hollande
et de Moscovici avec le nelsinou tout
une équipe quand on a fait un rapport il
y a donc à l'époque Hollande un rapport
sur la présence française économique en
Afrique on a constaté le recul parce que
les Africains ils sont ils sont pas plus
idiots que les autres ils sont ouverts à
la mondialisation il y a 15 ou 20
puissances qui sont prêts à investir à
faire des choses donc on perd des parts
de marché forcément bon et donc on avait
fait la liste de ce que devaient faire
les entreprises françaises ne pas faire
entreprise africaine gouvernement
présenté au sommet Afrique France après
il y a 15 chefs d'État il sont venus me
dire mais quel bonheur de lire ça on en
a r le volol de la France qui passe son
temps à se lacérer sur son passé ça nous
intéresse pas ça ça règle aucun problème
chez nous c'est que des choses à usage
interne chez vous on s'en fiche par que
vous disiez on est prêt à rester oui
très bien on veut pas être en tête
à-tête avec les Chinois par contre vous
n'êtes plus des privilégiés donc faut
accepter la mise en concurrence faut pas
considérer que parce que vous êtes la
France j' auriez automatiquement le pont
l'aéroport voyez il y a un climat et ça
fait maintenant 20 ans que je suis c'est
frappé de la différence entre les disons
les moments de convulsion sporadique en
France sur le sujet et puis ce que
disent les les dirigeants africains
c'est complètement différent voilà c'est
pour ça que je faisais le détour par le
rappel de l'héritage des des autres
donc on n pas rougir du passé on peut
pas rester s'il nous demande pas il y a
pas de raison que notre présence soit
essentiellement militaire c'était la
demande des Africains ça se termine si
ça doit recommencer je pense pas qu'il
faille dire plus jamais parce que ça
serait reconnaître qu'on a malagie on n
pas malagie en fait parfois
maladroitement mais pas mal il faudrait
quand même être très clair en disant on
ne peut revenir pour des opérations en
Afrique que ponctuellement
ponctuellement pour des durées précises
et à condition qu' a une demande
expresse au minimum des organisations
africaines dans l'idéal du Conseil de
sécurité ce qui s'était passé pour
turquoise dans l'affaire du Rwanda qui
est arrivé trop tard parce que les
Américains ont bloqué pendant 2 mois
pour d'autres raisons donc il y avait un
mandat limité dans le temps limité dans
l'espace une demande expresse précise
donc on va pas dire moi je dis pas que
ça n'arrivera plus jamais mais il faut
souhaiter que les Africains se dotent
d'une force
d'interposition ce qui fait que les
problèmes c'est eux qui les auront après
ils se disputeront après sur pourquoi
ils sont intervenus pas inter ça bon
mais je dirais pas fire mon la porte et
pour le reste il reste un champ énorme à
la l'influence française dès lors
qu'elle est moderne actuelle
papieromptoire il faut qu'on change de
ton ça c'est
global sur tous les autres terrains
économique culturel artistique Chang
humain sur tous les plans coopération
multiples évidemment sur les les
immenses chantiers de l'écologie de
demain l'écologisation ça c'est pas que
africain mais donc il y a un champ
énorme un champ énorme dans toute
l'Afrique mis à part les trois quatre
gouvernements du sel qui sont entrés
dans un cycle russe pour nous rejeter
mais encore une fois ça sera pas éternel
parce que ils vont régler aucun de leur
problème et donc il y a un champ énorme
donc voilà je termine là-dessus soyons
assez disponible assez ouvert toutag mut
et on ne garde la la porte entreouverte
pour des actions militaires à la demande
que dans des conditions très
précises voilà où j'en suis sur le sujet
je vous remercie c une introduction
extrêmement extrêmement
stimulante maintenant les les groupes
s'exprimer alors ce sont les groupes qui
sont mis d'accord je trouve que
l'équilibre entre les deux commissions
il est un peu un peu hasardeux mais
c'est pas grave mais je vous demande de
vous tenir bien dans les 2 minutes et
demi parce que il y a énormément de
choses à dire énormément
d'interlocuteurs je vous remercie
infiniment c'était très très éclairant
euh pour Renaissance madame
giverernet merci merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues merci monsieur le ministre
pour cet exposé très riche le président
de la République a ouvert un nouveau
chapitre dans les relations entre la
France et l'Afrique lors de son discours
à agadougu en 2017 le groupe Renaissance
soutient fermement ce partenariat
renouvelé fondé sur une relation d'égal
à égal avec l'Afrique cette nouvelle
dynamique se traduit par des engagements
sans précédent de la part de la France
un engagement pour la jeunesse tout
d'abord l'éducation est une priorité
absolue pour stimuler la croissance et
lutter contre les inégalités la France a
ainsi versé une contribution historique
de 330 millions d'euros en faveur du
Partenariat mondial pour l'éducation
notamment pour soutenir son accès aux
jeunes filles notre groupe considère
essentiel de poursuivre sur cette lancée
car l'école est la garantie d'un
développement durable pour le continent
un deuxième engagement porté haut par le
Président de la République vous l'avez
dit c'est celui de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique nous saluons en
ce sens l'organisation du One forest
submit par le Gabon et la France qui
aboutit à la création d'un fond de 100
million d'euros pour protéger les forêts
tropicales un sommet qui constitue une
première mondiale et qui doit être
renouvelé un dernier engagement qui nous
mobilise tous celui de la sécurité vous
l'avez évoqué dans votre propos et
notamment après la dissolution du G5
Sahel la France s'attache à promouvoir
des solutions strictement africaines
pour lutter contre le terrorisme et les
conflits sans interférer pourtant
l'image de notre pays est de plus en
plus abîmée sur le continent africain
alors que la France n'a rien à rougir de
rien c'est ce que vous avez dit j'en
veux pour preuve que le Mali lui-même a
dénoncé une instrumentalisation de
l'extérieur avant de quitter le G5 Sahel
j'en veux aussi pour preuve ces vidéos
antirançaises imputé à Wagner qui ont
été visionnés des centaines de milliers
de fois Monsieur le Ministre la Russie
renforce massivement sa présence en
Afrique sur les plans militaires
économique et de la désinformation ses
acteurs officiels et privés ciblent la
France pour nuire à sa réputation il
nous faut répondre à cette guerre de
l'image dans ce contexte monsieur le
ministre nous aimerions vous entendre
sur la manière dont nous devrions lutter
contre ces campagnes antirançaises et
faire face à l'accroissement de
l'influence russe sur le continent
quelle mesures concrètes pourrions-nous
rapidement mettre en place pour contrer
cette situation je vous remercie
beaucoup
oui monsieur le ministre bon madame j'ai
en partie répondu déjà avant maison
c'est le jeu ça euh pas pas enti Clement
je redis que dans l'avenir il faut être
guidé par la la demande des Africains
pas l'Afrique en général ça veut rien
dire ils sont pas tellement d'accord
entre eux en réalitéme quand on dit
l'Europe qui parle donc la demande des
Africains domaine par domaine c'est
assez différent donné cité plusieurs
domaines de coopération donc il faut se
fixer partir des demandes voir ce qu'on
peut apporter en réponse voir si c'est
vraiment nous est-ce que c'est le
gouvernement les entreprises ou quelque
chose d'Européens ou autrre faire du
adoc donc très très très pragmatique
c'est ce que je dis simplement à la
liste des sujets de coopération que vous
avveit cité à juste titre pour la
campagne entrée française encore une
fois on est dans une ambiance il y a il
y a un discours une rhtorique pour pas
dire un baratin anti-occidental c'est
pas vraiment vrai parce que les mêmes
dirigeants qui disent ça sont à la tête
de pays dans les gens dans lesquels les
gens rêvent de vivre à
l'occidentale pas sous la coupe des
occidentaux faut distinguer les deux
mais tout le monde veut vivre comme nous
on n jamais vu mieux que les sociétés
européennes dans l'histoire de
l'humanité en fait il y a 1000 choses à
réformer à corriger mais enfin il y a
pas historiquement ni géographiquement
mieux et les populations en Afrique sont
pareilles ils rêvent de vivre comme ça
donc les régim qui vont jouer que de ça
en se liant les mains avec des entités
ruchesut de toute façon il répondra à
rien ils peuvent rien réjoutre des
problèmes de ces malheureuses
populations donc faut être assez
confiant
et on peut pas les empêcher dans
l'immédiat de de raconter les sautices
qui racontent après tout le monde actuel
est une gigantesque bataille d'influence
ce n'est pas une communauté
internationale passe encore et toutes
les puissances et emploi s procédés il y
a on pourrait parler des islamistes des
réseaux islamistes qui sont eux par
exemple qui ont torpillé le planning
familial au nigerre depuis des années
des années donc ouais il faut être dans
la bataille d'influence mais en le
faisant froidement calmement
méthodiquement pas militairement mais
méthodiquement pas être trop
trop épouvanté nous-même par le fait
qu'on ose nous attaquer avec des
mensonges monumentaux on se mais comment
les gens peuvent croire ça regardez aux
États-Unis il y a la moitié de la
population qui croit des choses
complètement anticientifiques donc c'est
effrayant mais je propose de le traiter
très avec un sang frroid gigantesque et
en attendant que ça se retourne donc
faut NRE des aliments faut communiquer
nous aussi faut être sur les réseaux et
C voilà des fois on en fait un peu
trop et ça donne des arguments faut pas
avoir peur de la des manœuvres Russ en
plus c'est pas le continent hein la
Russie elle essaie de revenir dans 400
pays qui sont des pays qui sont au fond
du trou hein voilà oui c'est vrai mais
froidement j'essaie de vous contenir
dans 2 minutes 30 je suis absolument non
non mais à peine mais je suis
extrêmement répressif excusez-moi pour
le RN monsieur
fffer merci Messieurs les Présidents
monsieur le ministre je tiens d'abord à
vous remercier pour votre présence vous
qui avez inscrit la politique étrangère
de François mitteran dans la lignée de
la vision gouliste en contribuant à
façonner une approche réaliste mais
aussi en mettant en avant le rôle
central des États en tant qu'acteur
historique légitime et pertinent c'est
une vision de la diplomatie que nous
partageons c'est pourquoi je me permets
aujourd'hui de mettre en avant nos
préoccupations quant à la direction de
notre diplomatie sous la présidence
d'Emmanuel Macron qui depuis 6 ans ne
semble avoir aucune ligne directrice et
est plongé dans un flou regrettable les
illustrations sont nombreuses mais le
temps nous manque ce matin j'en viendrai
donc directement à l'Afrique qui est
l'exemple type de l'échec de cette
politique du en même
temps tant la dégradation des relations
entre la France et les peuples et
nations africaines est importante
Emmanuel Macron voulait tout changer
après les présidents Sarkozi et Hollande
et au final le continent est toujours
aussi instable mais en plus la France
voit ses intérêts être remise en cause
notamment par nos compétiteurs qui eux
ne nous attendent pas Russie
chine-turquie l'ancien président
tchadien debit disait la France doit
avoir une politique africaine et au sein
de celle-ci des priorités et des
alliances privilégiées avec ses amis
historiques et nous le pensons aussi
contrairement au président Macron qui
lui a affirmé à deux reprises qu'il n'y
avait plus de politique africaine de la
France nous pensons qu'il y a plus que
jamais besoin d'une politique africaine
de la France pour prévenir lesmigration
sécuriser nos ressortissants dynamiser
la la francophonie mais aussi développer
nos échanges commerciaux qui sont
insuffisants alors monsieur le ministre
nous aurions beaucoup de questions à
vous poser pour profiter de votre
expérience mais je me limiterai à en
poser deux vous qui défendez un rôle
central des états- nation que
pensez-vous de la volonté d'Emmanuel
Macron de renoncer à certains pan de
notre diplomatie au profil de l'Union
européenne dans quelle limite cela
est-il selon vous concevable et
acceptable et concernant l'Afrique tout
particulièrement ne pensez-vous pas que
la France aurait à gagner en défendant
la proposition d'un siège de membres
permanents de l'Afrique au sein du
Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU monsieur le
ministre
je rappelle que si j'ai utilise la
formule
golomitérandisme c'est sur la question
de la dissuasion à l'origine c'est pas
expliquer quand François mitéron avait
repris cet acqui là après c élargi à une
partie de la politique étrangère mais
pas au-delà bon c'est un rappel
historique d'autre part on peut pas
attribuer Emmanuel on n'est pas obligé
d'ê d'accord avec tout ce qu'a fait le
président depuis qu'il est là mais on
peut pas attribuer à Emmanuel Macron
toutes les problèmes en Afrique c'est
absurde il y anormément de problèmes en
dehors des zones d'influence
français il y a beaucoup de dirigeants
africains qui ont énormément aimé
beaucoup d'initiative du président pas
toutes enfin c'est le débat normal ça
donc cette présentation est exagérée et
puis encore une fois il y a plein de
pays en Afrique qui ont des problèmes
énormes alors qu'il y a aucune influence
française regardez la façon dont
l'Afrique du Sud est de plus en plus un
un gros pays africain normal avec 36
problèmes on y est pour rien bon donc il
faut à mon avis relativiser par rapport
à ça quant aux initiatives qui a pris le
le Président je crois pouvoir Macron je
crois pvoir dire que les élites
africaines sont plutôt favorable plutôt
sympathie avec ce qu'il a tenté même
quand ça marche pas sauf les élites qui
ont des problèmes tels avec leur peuple
parce qu'ils arrivent à rien eux-mêmes
qu'ils ont besoin d'un bémissaire et là
on retombe sur la France par rapport à
ça bon bref c'est plus c'est plus
compliqué les questions migratoires en
effet je parlerai un autre moment mais
moi je pense que l'Europe sera obligée
de se mettre sur la ligne en gros des ch
déémocrate danois un jour ou l'autre et
donc c dira une discussion compliquée
avec les Africains même nos amis la
forcherie les autres mais c'est pour
plus tard et je sais pas si c'est hor
sujet mais bon on verra rien sujet r
sujet sur le siège à l'enu euh ça fait
très longtemps que Alain jupet et moi on
a dit la France est ouverte à une
réforme du Conseil de sécurité qui
représente le monde de 45 on y est grâce
à chchill je vous rappelle hein c'est
chchill à Yalta qui s'est battu contre
Roosevelt et Staline qui trouvait l'idé
ridicule pour mettre la France mettre la
France parce qu'il craignaiit une
revanche allemande encore une fois donc
la France est là grâce à Churchill bon
et pour changer le Conseil de sécurité
il faut
l'unanimité faut qu'il y ait pas de veto
alors depuis qu'on a dit Jup et moi euh
pas en même temps à la suite quand on a
dit on est tout à fait d'accord il faut
qu'il y ait le Japon l'Inde un pays
africain un pays latino-américain la
Chine a dit moi jeux pas le Japon ni
l'Inde et puis les Américains ont dit on
va pas bouger comme ça et les Africains
n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord sur
le fait que le représentant c'est le
président de l'Union africaine par
exemple donc il bouge pas en plus les
Arabes disent mais nous on est refait
dans l'affaire parce que comme on n'est
pas identifié un continent particulier
on est nulle part bon donc la France n'a
rien à se reprocher là-dessus elle est
même assez ouverte et donc il y a aucun
reproche à faire à la France même dans
les disons les africains les plus les
plus excités de Paris sur la France par
un point à ça je vous remercie je temp
c'est marqué là voz 3 minutes non mais
c'est
c'est c'est affreux mais je dis l'invité
je je baisse les bras pas pas
complètement pour la France insoumise
c'est Monsieur
Fernandez il est
où pas de souci pas de problème merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais d'abord commencer
par vous remercier d'être présent devant
nos deux commissions en tant qu'ancien
ministre des Affaires étrangères et
secrétaire général de l'Élysée vous
bénéficiez d'une bonne appréciation du
fonctionnement de l'appareil
diplomatique et militaire français et
notamment en Afrique mon groupe souhaite
connaître votre avis sur les échecs
récents de la diplomatie des et des
services de renseignement dans leur
capacité à voir venir les coups d'État
au Mali au Burkina Faso et au Niger
notamment est-ce que le fait que la
France et les partenaires militaires du
Mali aent uniquement focalisé l'approche
sur la lutte contre le le terrorisme
djihadiste euh crucial évidemment et de
première importance n'y est pas pour
beaucoup alors que cette dimension ne
résume pas pour autant le contexte dans
sa totalité aussi nous proposons depuis
longtemps la mise en place d'une loi de
programmation du quai d'Orsa sur la base
de la loi de programmation militaire
dans quelle mesure selon vous
serait-elle utile pour construire une
stratégie de politique étrangère à plus
long terme notamment en Afrique et à ce
titre nous tenons à rappeler
l'attachement de notre groupe au corps
diplomatique dont l'expertise et le
trava dévoué participe au rayonnement de
notre pays et à la qualité de son
service public de la diplomatie en outre
et plus généralement comment voyez-vous
l'avenir de la relation de la France au
pays d'Afrique dans le cadre des
différentes dynamiques de recompositions
actuelles mon groupe ne cesse de le
répéter nous pensons que ce n'est pas la
France qui est rejetée lorsqu'elle est
rejetée vous l'avez dit ça n'est pas le
cas dans l'ensemble des pays d'Afrique
mais c'est une certaine idée de la
France et des actes politiques ou
diplomatiques encore très imprégné de
poste colonialisme post-colonialisme ou
de paternalisme nous prenons pour notre
part depuis longtemps une coopération au
service des peuples de France et des
pays d'Afrique pour faire face au défis
de l'humanité à venir au premier rang
desquels le réchauffement climatique qui
touche de manière particulièrement
intense le continent africain à l'heure
de la clôture d'une COP 28 pour le moins
décevante francophonie coopération
scientifique développement et
émancipation économique comment selon
vous la France peut-elle humblement
opérer un tournant dans les différentes
relations bilatérales avec les pays
arique autrement dit pensez-vous que la
France soit capable d'adopter la posture
d'humilité nécessaire à une telle
évolution de sa politique vis-à-vis des
États africains je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député
monsieur le ministre humilité c'est un
peu trop hein à peu trop d'ailleurs
aucun Africain ne pensait si on est
devenait imp c'est pas notre nature on
y'y arrivera pas mais il nous prendrait
pas du tout au sérieux si on simplement
disons moins prétentieux moins pérorant
moins déclamatoire ça serait déjà
formidable euh ensuite les échecs on
pourrait se demander pourquoi les les
Américains même et Zelinski lui-même ne
croyaient pas à l'attaque russe euh
pourquoi les Israéliens n'ont pas vu
venir l'attaque du Hamas c'était le cas
d'ailleurs déjà deux fois avant dans des
guerres israélo-arabes bon donc même les
services les mieux les plus compétents
peuvent se tromper dans l'analyse faut
distinguer c'est pas évident d'avoir des
informations et peut-être que vous avez
donné la réponse une sorte de
focalisation sur la seule question
terroriste et que donc ça n'a pas été vu
bon c'est pas un problème gigantesque
sur la loi de
programmation pour le qu d'oré moi je
suis je suis pas en fonction mais je
suis forcément pour d'ailleurs quand le
Kor le budget du Kor était matraqué
façon disproportionné à la JEP et moi on
avait pris fait un article en commun
pour dire ça suffit stop on avait ça
avit ralenti le truc un an ou deux après
ça a continué c'est une erreur
fondamentale c'est un budget ridicule
c'est de de 1 % la moindre diminution
des conséquences énormes dans les pays
dans lesquels on a on a fermé des
centres arrêté les Bours et ce donc
bravo pour l' programmation quant à la
au corps j'ai bien entendu ce que vous
avez dit je pense que la le vrai
problème c'est que dans l'institut
comment s'appelle l' inssp c'est ça le
nouvel institut service public disons la
professionnalisation n'est pas assurée
alors ça c'est l'élément clé alors je
reviens pas sur les motifs bons ou
mauvais sur la la réforme qui a eu lieu
mais on peut pas être la seule puissance
au Monde qui n'est plus de filière
professionnalisante pour le métier
diplomatique laité de négociation ça
s'improvise pas en fait mais c'est
encore jouable mais il y a deux
tonalités quand on regarde les
responsables certains disent non faut
absolument casser le fait que les gens
fassent leur carrière dans une même
activité non il y a un métier quand même
bon moi je suis pour la logique de
métier c'est un combat qui est devant
n bien c'est très clair c'est raccourci
c'est c'est oui c'est impératoria
brevitas Monsieur monsieur le ministre
pour les républicains madame
tabarotoups monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
venir échanger avec nous ce matin pour
nous permettre de bénéficier de votre
regard expérimenté sur la situation
actuelle avec mon collègue Bruno fou le
président l'a rappel nous avons
récemment rendu un rapport sur les
relations entre la France et l'Afrique
dans le cadre du quel vous aviez été
entendu nous y parlons évidemment de la
perte d'influence de la France sur ce
continent il y a des causes externes à
notre pays avec l'attitude souvent
déloyale de nos compétiteurs
stratégiques ou bien le comportement des
jeunes qui font de nous des bouques
émissaires mais il y a aussi des causes
qui sont propres à notre pays ainsi
l'annonce de la fin de la politique
africaine de la France par François
Hollande puis par Emmanuel Macron ont
été une erreur d'ailleurs ils ont été
rattrapés par la réale politique et on a
sentiment depuis le discours de l'Élysée
de février dernier que le chef de l'État
tente de dessiner une nouvelle stratégie
malheureusement elle se heurte à un
certain nombre de constats sur lesquels
j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment déjà
sur le plan stratégique partagez-vous le
constat d'une centralisation excessive
et d'un manque de concertation très
dommageable à la cohérence de nos
actions s'agissant ensuite de l'aide
public au développement qui devrait être
notre principal atout qu'en pensez-vous
euh est-ce qu'elle est ou non
suffisamment mise au service de nos
intérêts même question sur euh pour nos
médias publ en Afrique qui diffusent
trop souvent des critiques et une image
négative de la France ne doivent-ils pas
s'employer un peu plus à valoriser les
actions positives de la France je
pourrais aussi parler de nos armées de
nos valaleureux soldats avec la
réflexion en cours sur l'offre
stratégique sur laquelle vous avez
peut-être un avis à partager monsieur le
ministre toutes ces questions peuvent se
résumer en une seule la France a le
potentiel d'avoir une diplomatie
d'influence parmi les plus puissantes au
monde d'après vous pourquoi
n'arriv-t-elle pas aujourd'hui à mieux
l'utiliser pour en faire une véritable
force je vous remercie madame la députée
monsieur le
ministre encore une fois je rappelle que
dans le cadre dans lequel nous
réfléchissons il y a pas que la France
les Occidentaux n'ont plus le monopole
de l'influence dans le monde la
puissance et la richesse pas le monopole
ça fait 20 ans que je dis ça ça fait 20
ans que des Chinois me rétorquent non
c'est la fin de la parenthèse
occidentale je suis pas sur la ligne de
la parenthèse c'est pas vrai mais il y a
quand même une grosse partie du monde
qui pense ça donc chaque fois que vous
pensez France rappelez-vous que c'est
pas un phénomène français spécifique il
y a pas une limitation de l'influence
française dans un monde où l'ensemble de
l'Occident a une influence phénoménale
c'est l'inverse et je redis la
distinction entre les gouvernements et
les peuples qui voudraient vivre à
l'Occident si c'était possible donc faut
pas prendre les choses sous un angle un
peu masochiste pour qu'on la question
n'est pas celle du
posteconialisme Y a qui a disparu il y a
plus rien en fait en réalité c'est la
question des Bou émissaires dont ils ont
besoin donc c'est la même réponse que
celle que j'ai fait avant la stratégie
c'est celle de la disponibilité on peut
pas c'est contradictoire de dire on va
partir des demandes des Africains et de
dire voilà la stratégie la stratégie
c'est d'être disponible agile prê à
rebondir à répondre aux demandes qui
sont innombrables contradictoires entre
elles entre les différents gouvernements
les différents m dépens on parle aux
entreprises ou autres aux ONG aux
associations des organisations fa un
pays qui soit très très disponible qui
réinvestisse dans la proximité
sociologique amicale culturelle
linguistique avec l'Afrique et là-dessus
on pourra rebattir une stratégie en
réponse mais on peut pas la décréter
tout seul quant à la FB la FD d'accord
vous avez raison mais quand j'avais mené
le travail dont je vous ai parlé la
plupart des pays nous disons on n' plus
besoin d'aide en fait on veut de l'accès
au marché on veut des investissements on
veut des actions communes dans des
technologies avancées mais l'aide en
plus on sait jamais si ça sert à quelque
chose voyez donc oui pour l'aide mais ça
peut pas être le seul je nuance un peu
ça peut pas être le seul élément de la
stratégie de
disponibilité 2 minutes parfait parfait
vous euh oui euh maintenant c'est pour
le groupe démocrate c'est Madame
dariuseg jeunev c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président euh
monsieur le ministre merci de votre
présence et de nos échanges
euh j'ai été très nous sommes très
attentifs et et je retiens ce que vous
avez dit qui je crois doit être notre
ligne il ne faut pas rougir de ce ce que
nous avons fait de ce que nous sommes
euh et nous devons bien sûr agir avec la
volonté des Africains c'est euh c'est la
la ligne initiale qui doit qui doit nous
nous nous tenir en permanence rien faire
sans les africains mais avec leur
volonté vous avez répondu à beaucoup de
beaucoup de questions et et euh je
retiens quand même dans ce que vous avez
dit vous avez parlé fait référence au
discours de François mitéran à La Baule
en disant 990 qui parlait d'aider plus
favorablement les pays qui avancent vers
la démocratie doit-on continuer en tant
que nation prenant bien sûr la
démocratie et les droits de l'homme
apporter ses valeurs au niveau du
continent africain et à conditionner nos
aides euh à ces euh à ces à ce que les
pays portent ses valeurs et deuxème
question dans l'aide au développement
dont nous venons de parler euh ce terme
aide au développement est je crois
péjoratif pour l'Afrique il faut que
nous changions de paradigme
euh afin que nous puissions avoir un
véritable coopération entre nations qui
se sentent sur le même pied d'égalité et
qui se respectent et je crois que cela
sera peut-être un avenir différent avec
le peuple
africain je vous remercie madame madame
le ministre monsieur le
ministre quand j'ai dit ne pas rougir du
passé ça veut pas dire refuser
l'histoire je pense à ça il y a on a
fait des erreurs géantes assz souvent il
peut même y avoir eu des des choses
vraiment condamnables ponctuellement
mais de pas rir globalement comme si
historiquement c'était épouvantable
c'est là-dessus la distinction mais
autant je suis contre le devoir de
mémoire qui est une fabrication en
réalité qui dépend de l'état d'esprit du
rapport des forces dans le pays qui
fabrique le devoir de mémoire autant je
suis à fond pour l'histoire totalement
librement sur tous ces sujets y compris
Cuxa bon je reviens un peu en arrière
mais je réponds sur les valeurs c'est un
énorme sujet mais comment dire l'idée
que l'Occident et à continué son travail
prosélite l'Occident missionnaire quoi
en fait ça marche plus vraiment sinon on
n'aurait pas ce résultat quand Poutine a
attaqué l'Ukraine c'est incontestable il
y a quand même 40 pays représentant les
2/ers de l'humanité qui n'ont pas voulu
choisir ils sont pas pour la Guer ils
sont même pas pour Poutine ils veulent
pas dans notre camp les horreurs du
Proche-Orient vous avez un bloc
occidental en gros un bloc musulman en
gros et plein d'asiatiques qui disent
nous on s'en fiche on peut pas fonder
toute notre action sur le prosélitisme
c'est plus possible alors ça c'est très
dur à dire parce que je me fais un
jourer quand je dis ça mais une grande
partie de l'Occident pense que c'est
notre mission la mission universelle
mais il faut être quand même un réaliste
et un peu froid par exemple quand on dit
la France patrie des Droits de l'Homme
normalement les gens applaudissent
automatiquement mais Badinter a toujours
dit non on est la patrie de la
déclaration ça veut dire qu'on a pas de
baguette magique pour transformer la la
Russie en un gros Danemark et si tout le
discours disons sur les valeurs
propulsées par l'Occident depuis la fin
de l'URS du C on nit pas peur donc on
l'a beaucoup développé s'il fonctionné
Poutine aurait jamais
attaqué la Chine serait pas devenue ce
qu'elle est elle serait restée sur la
ligne d' xaoping et même au proch
été différent donc c'est triste à dire
parce qu'on est fabriqué comme ça et un
de mes sujets de réflexion mais j'ai pas
la réponse je suis désolé c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un Occident non
prosélite qui a envie que ces valeurs se
propagent mais plutôt du fait de la
dynamique interne des pays qui les gens
veulent être respectés les droits
humains fondamentaux partout sans qu'on
ait besoin d'intervenir en envoyant des
missionnaires et j'ai pas la réponse à
ça parce que c'est tellement fondamental
dans l'Occident aussi bien à droite qu'à
gauche que c'est très compliqué qu'on se
réinvente comme une entité qui veut
absolument défendre sa civilisation son
mode de vie mais pas forcément en
l'imposant à l'ensemble des autres et
là-dessus je suis plus proche de
levistros que de beaucoup de
d'intervenants actuels je pose les
questions mais j'ai pas la réponse et là
je suis trop long
désolé ça
serait maintenant pour les socialistes
c'est Alain David monsie merci monsieur
le
Président Monsieur le président des des
commissions monsieur le ministre chers
collègues merci tout d'abord monsieur le
ministre pour votre propos
liminaire qui alimente notre réflexion
collective et nourrit utilement les
travaux de nos deux commissions cette
discussion sur la nouvelle donne
africaine anime nos débats tant en
commission que dans l'hémicycle comme ce
fut le cas le 21 novembre dernier pour
le groupe des députés socialistes et
apparentés nous avions interrogé les
raisons profondes de cette évolution
accélérée entre par exemple le lancement
de l'opération Serval en 2013 salué par
les populations et la série récente de
coups d'État qui s'accompagne d'une
remise en cause de la présence française
en
Afrique un partenariat renouvelé avec
les pays africains est donc
impérieusement nécessaire chaque pays
avec ses particularisme doit concentrer
laattention de notre diplomatie et nous
devons combattre idée d'un Occident
égoïste qui ne nourit des accords
qu'entre pays développés et uvrait au
contraire à un réel
multilatéralisme la France possède
encore des atouts du professionnalisme
et de l'excellence de nos diplomates à
l'atout formidable de la Francophonie de
notre audiovisuel extérieur respecté à
l'attractivité encore importante de
notre enseignement secondaire dans les
pays africains et supérieur en France il
convient donc d'aborder la relation avec
les pays africains avec optimisme mais
également vigilance en ne reproduisant
pas les les récentes erreurs et en
tenant compte surtout du nouvel ordre
global né du conflit en Ukraine queles
sont d'ailleurs selon vous les
conséquences immédiates et de plus long
terme de cette nouvelle donne
internationale sur notre relation avec
les pays africains à votre avis notre
diplomatie parlementaire peut-elle
apporter sa contribution à
l'amélioration des relations dans la
complémentarité la diversité des
structures parlementaire merci je vous
remercie monsieur le député monsieur le
ministre moi je suis très favorable je
l'ai dit au début à ce que l'on aille
beaucoup plus en Afrique disons les
choses simplement faut y aller plus faut
voir les gens faut aller dans tous les
pays il faut discuter avec eux plein de
fois donc il faut arrêter de penser un
terme l'Afrique soit l'Afrique globale
ça fonctionne pas soit projeté sur
l'Afrique soit nos remords soit nos
projets qui fonctionnent pas c'est trop
global c'est trop artificiel c'est c'est
creux en fait en revangeche plus il y
aura de de parlementaires comme vous
plus il y aura de en France de
responsables variés d'associations de
journalistes de C cela qui iront en
Afrique pour des réunions en parlant
avec les gens plus on se rapprochera de
ce qui est l'Afrique Les Afriques
aujourd'hui et demain et plus on a des
chances de répondre et quand j'ai parlé
de disponibilité tout à l'heure ça peut
pas être une disponité abstraite dans le
vide fa avoir une bonne connaissance de
ce qui se passe dans tous les pays alors
il y a des des tas de gens qui qui le
font très bien dans des domaines
spécialisés par exemple dans les cops
alors elles sont décevantes mais s'il y
avait pas de Cop ce serait pire donc
c'est mieux dans les cops il y a plein
de négociations y comprisc les Africains
dans les discussions du G20 il y a plein
d'Africains et cetera et cetera donc il
faut réinvestir parce que
malheureusement dans la liquidation de
la francearique qui évidemment vous
pouvez pas continuer à coup de Val de
billet c'est l'époque Bongo c'est autre
chose ça évidemment il fallait liquider
tout ça mais ça c'est accompagné d'un
désinvestissement intellectuel massif
donc je suis absolument pour ce que vous
disez en terme de
présence merci infiniment
euh maintenant j'ai pour horizon madame
le
naaf le Enan excusez-moi c'est le enanf
c'est ça oui excusez-moi je déteste
qu'on écorche mon nom et donc je je je
ressens je me sens tout à fait coupable
je me sens tout à fait coupable d'avoir
écorché le vôtre je peux pas l'écorcher
votre
nom voilà je je vous pardonne monsieur
le Président monieur Messieurs les
Présidents monsieur le ministre au nom
de mon groupe je souhaite tout d'abord
vous remercier d'avoir accepté cette
invitation conjointe et de vos propos
introductif vraiment intéressant et ce
d'autant plus qu'on réfléchiss sur le
sujet depuis quelques semaines et donc
c'est ça apporte vraiment un éclairage
nouveau le mois dernier donc en
commission la défense avons entamé notre
cycle Afrique avec l'audition de
plusieurs leaders de Think Tank de
scientifiques de
chercheurs et j'avais souhaité les
interroger sur les partenariats entre la
France et les pays africains à ma
question est-ce que de votre côté les
pays africain l'envie de développer et
de renforcer nos partenariats est
toujours présente il m'avait répondu
oui je souhaiterais rebondir sur les
annonces du président de la République
en février dernier sur sa définition
d'une nouvelle approche de ce que l'on
peut appeler la politique africaine de
la France à l'ône de ce qui s'est
récemment passé dans plusieurs pays du
Sahel vous l'aurez compris ma question
portera davantage sur nos perspectives
que sur le bilan de la politique de la
France au regard de votre expérience
monsieur le ministre pensez-vous que
nous que pensez-vous qu'il y a
réellement du côté africain une envie de
France de de travailler de coopérer avec
la France ici à l'Assemblée nationale
nous avons on l'a exprimé publiquement
vraiment envie d'avoir une approche
nouvelle de changer peut-être n nos
approches et nous croyons beaucoup en la
diplomatie parlementaire notamment comme
en témoigne le cycle Afrique au sein des
commissions de la défense et des
Affaires étrangères en parallèle
plusieurs déplacements de délégations
parlementaires ont été effectuées ou
auront lieu prochainement pensez-vous
que la nouvelle nouvelle approche
destinée par le Président de la
République nous donne toutes les chances
de développer de renforcer nos
partenariats dans différents domaines si
oui lesquels j'aimerais avoir votre
opinion sur finalement la la
priorisation des partenariats que nous
pourrions avoir avec les pays africains
et et et selon les les plaques
géographiques
ou compte tenu des derniers événements
pourrait-on penser qu'il est encore trop
tôt pour cela qu'il existe de telles
crises
passions voir j'ose dire un rejet qui
pourrait décaler dans le temps
finalement des relations partenariales
apaisées et équilibrées je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la députée
monsieur le
ministre moi je n'ai aucun doute sur le
fait que beaucoup d'Africains veulent
maintenir des relation étroite avec la
France voir les développer j'ai aucun
doute là-dessus et tous les contacts que
j'ai depuis ces dernières années vont
dans ce sens ils veulent pas on l'a dit
on est tous d'accord ils veulent pas de
la France arrogante mais est incapable
de d'être elle a plutôt tendance à raser
les murs là maintenant donc les
Africains sont pas à l'aise avec ça je
l'ai dit la repentance ça les intéresse
pas ils veulent une France moderne
pragmatique présente capable de réagir
en disponibilité donc c'est pas à nous
de faire la liste à priori la liste elle
découlera de tous les contacts depuis le
président son action été rappelé à
plusieurs reprises les ministres les
parlementaires et tout le monde par
rapport à ça qu'on son en Phe avec en
prise avec l'Afrique d'aujourd'hui alors
évidemment ils sont eux-mêm dans le
monde global il y a énormément de
bagares au sein de l'Afrique au sein de
l'Union africaine donc on pas CER à
l'Afrique et c'est pas nous de choisir à
priori il faut voir domaine par domaine
est-ce qu'on est dans le domaine
agricole ou économique en général ou
technologie ou écologie on trouvera des
partenaires à géométrie variable donc
faut pas s'enfermer dans des schémas
faut pas les les proclamer par rapport à
ça et puis on verra comment en termme de
perspective je pense que l'Afrique sera
jamais unifié aura jamais un pouvoir
africain global pour peser dans les
affaires du monde donc quand les gens
disent il y aura 2 milliards d'habitants
c'est le centre du monde de demain c'est
n'importe quoi ça bon le le seul
problème un peu compliqué à gérer mais
on y arrivera c'est quand l'Europe
finira par dire bon sur l'immigration
faut quand même être sérieux on a besoin
de gens mais pas n'importe comment et
les regroupement familial a été détourné
le droit d'asile est totalement détourné
blab blabbla donc on va faire une
négociation sérieuse à partir de cota
par métier comme font les donc les
Scandinaves avec les pays de départ
transit alors au départ on va s'arracher
les cheveux ils vont dire l'Europe
forteresse alors que c'est exactement
l'inverse bon et au bout de 3 4 ans ça
deviendra une relation à mon avis
structurante
entre l'Europe de demain le Schengen
redynamisé et les pays partenaires mais
donc je suis sûr du point d'arrivée mais
ça peut prendre 10 ans entre-temps il se
peut qu'il a un moment donné des tension
comme on l'a vu ponctuellement quand le
président Macron avait décidé de réagir
au fait que les pays de Maghreb ne
prennent jamais les gens qui ont été
condamnés 10 fois et qu'on arrive pas à
expulser il avait raison donc il a serré
sur les visas crise gigantesque dont on
sort bon on aura ça avec les certains
pays d'Afrique certains mais comme les
3/4 des Africains qui é migre pour vivre
mieux je parle pas de l'asile qui est
détourné bon vivre mieux ils vont plutôt
au Nigéria si c'est possible en Afrique
du Sud qui se dit elle-même envahie par
les pulions migratoires donc moi je
m'attends à quelques années un peu
difficiles et à l'arrivée une relation
beaucoup plus saine permettant d'aborder
les autres questions c'està dire voilà
on est disponible et parlons de ce qui
vous intéresse et il y aura des des
dizaines de réponses
différentes en vous écoutant je me dis
que ça serait utile que vous soyez memre
de la commission mix paritaire mais ça
va pas être possible
euh au titre des noninscrits euh donc le
dernier orateur au titre des groupes
c'est Monsieur
duponteignan
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour ses paroles
très
sages moi j'ai trois questions et je les
introduirai à partir des témoignages que
j'ai souvent reçu d'interlocuteurs très
divers en Amérique latine en Afrique au
Moyen-Orient et ce qui est intéressant
en tout cas ce que j'ai retenu c'est
qu'ils me disent tous la même chose ils
sont pourtant de pays différents ils
sont de couleur politique très
différentes et ils avouent quand même
toujours en privé leur extrême déception
à l'égard de la France et ils disent
tous la même chose nous ne reconnaissons
plus la France et il regrette plusieurs
choses il regrettent d'abord de ne pas
avoir d'interlocuteur à Paris fiable
certes il y a le président de la
République mais derrière et moi
j'aimerais avoir première question
monsieur le ministre votre analyse sur
l'organisation de notre politique
étrangère le sentiment que il y a le
président de la République une vague
cellule à l'Élysée et puis derrière plus
rien comment ça se passe pourquoi il y a
cette déception fondamentale sentiment
de pas être écouté de pas être reçu de
pas être traité tout simplement deuxième
point la cohérence ils disent tous la
même chose on comprend pas la politique
de la France d'un côté il y a l'aréal
politique par exemple le Tchad de
l'autre il y a les leçons de morale au
Niger quelle cohérence aussi entre le
discours du kéorsa et celui de la FD on
n'est pas capable d'avoir un soutien sur
un problème concrets alors on va vers où
on va vers les Chinois ça prend 2 ans de
moins par lafd l'Union européenne ça
n'avancera pas problème de cohérence
générale et puis enfin et là j'ai une
question fondamentale pour moi et je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez est-ce
qu'il y a pas un lien aussi très fort
entre notre perte d'influence et
l'alignement systématique a commencé
avec le retour dans l'organisation
militaire intégré de
l'OTAN sur les États-Unis que ce soit en
Ukraine au Proche Orient une sorte de
déception c'est quand même un paradoxe
que le général de Gaulle au moment on
était en pleine carerre froide s'adresse
à un monde multipolaire l'anticipe à
cette vision du monde multipolaire et au
moment où il y a le monde multipolaire
la France a disparu ne s'adresse plus à
ce monde multipolaire elle est
complètement alignée et ça ça a des
conséquences je pense sur le regard que
portent les peuples du Sud global comme
on dit sur notre pays et l'extrême
déception qu'ils ont ils aimeraient
entendre une voix forte de la France sur
les grands dossiers du monde et ils ont
l'impression qu'elle s'est
évanoui je vous remercie monsieur le
député de ces questions effectivement
fondamental à laquelle je pense monsieur
Vedrine va avoir beaucoup d'intérêt à
répondre
et beaucoup de mal en 1 minute 30 bien
sûr mais alors face à une telle
interpellation on va vous donner jusqu'à
2 minutes 45 non mais ça ça mérite le le
point 3 mérite une un échange en
particulier bon euh déception moi je
suis tout à fait pour revigorer le C
d'oré ça passe par différents sujets
déjà abordé avant il faut revigorer il
compris le métier il compris les moyens
il compris la disponibilité là on est
dans une sorte de phase un peu abolique
et bien sûr alors en même temps ceux qui
vous disent ça ils jouent un peu parce
qu'il ils ont les contact quand même ils
se plaignent ils veulent obtenir plus
bon il y a il y a une part de jeu de
négociation mais c'est vrai qu'on peut
entendre ça
et je crois qu'on a vraiment besoin de
revigorer retaper
repréfessionionnaliser les loges du
métier et cetera je suis d'accord
làdessus sur la la cohérence on n
arrivera jamais totalement cohérent
c'est comme l'affaire du deux poids de
mesurees en fait il y a 10 poids 10
mesures dans les relations
internationales donc faut arrêter le le
discours après on s'adapte le M faut pas
êre je défends pas l'incohérence je sais
bien qu'on bon c'est difficile il vaut
mieux être cohérent mais il vaut mieux
pas donner des leçons sans arrêt sans
arrêt donc je reviens à la France
pirorante quand on est les maîtres du
monde comme Louis XIV on peut dire ce
qu'on veut ou Napoléon au début mais on
n'est pas dans ces situations donc je
plaide pour un discours beaucoup plus je
l'ai j'ai donné plusieurs exemples sur
les droits de l'homme je PL pour un
discours on renonce à rien de ce qu'on
est de ce qu'on veut bien sûr mais qu'on
arrête de faire la leçon à tout le monde
ce que vous avez dit sur la France c'est
vrai sur l'Europe hein P ça que les
Africains il préfèrent faire affaire
avec des Chinois quit à s'en mordre les
doigts après 10 ans après trop endetté
parce que la Chine nose pas de critères
démocratique ceci cela bon faut pas
basculer on peut pas renoncer à ce qu'on
est non plus donc je suis d'accord
soyons plus cohérents moins cohérent
déjà ce serait bien quand à la perte
d'influence bon est-ce qu'il y a
l'affaire des Occidentaux en général
encore une fois ne par ne raisonnait pas
comme si la France était le seul pays
occidental bizarrement qui a perdu son
influence alors que tous les autres
éclapent d'influence non non et regardez
l'état des États-Unis c'est quoi la
politique américaine dans un an voez
c'est c'est pas que c'est pas que
français mais est-ce qu'il y a un lien
oui je suis d'accord il il y a quand
même un peu un
avec une certaine banalisation mais je
parle pas de la présidence actuelle
c'est un phénomène sur beaucoup depuis
la depuis la fin de jacirac on va dire
il y a quand même une tendance une
banalisation occidentalisation alors
mais civilation occidentale bien sûr
tous les pays du monde veulent être
dedans mais il n'empêche qu'en terme
géopolitique s'il y a quelque chose à
corriger peut-être je suis d'accord il
faut peut-être réinventer le golom
mitérandisme voir le Golis si vous
voulez je je vous remercie je vais
passer maintenant c'est c'est c'est
Thomas qui va qui va gérer la seconde
partie je voudrais moi vous poser quand
même une question j'ai bien compris
plusieurs messages le premier message il
y a des Afriques et pas une Afrique
c'est très clair deuxième message nous
ne sommes pas les sauveurs du genre
humain c'est la France même si regretons
oui dommage mais alors je vous pose on
est quand même confronté nous avons été
très Obs
au cours des dernières années par
l'Afrique de l'Ouest or ce qui apparaît
comme évident c'est l'immensité et la
tragédie absolue des problèmes de
l'Afrique de l'Est que ce soit l'est du
Congo la région des lacs des Grands Lacs
le Soudan qui est une horreur absolue
l'Éthiopie le Tigré tout cela compose un
paysage absolument terrifiant et est-ce
comment peut-on à partir de ce que nous
ce que nous n sommes plus et à partir ce
que nous sommes encore comment peut-on
nous Français nous européens nous
occidentaux peut-on intervenir pas
intervenir mais peut-on contribuer à
trouver un apaisement une solution dans
cette
Afrique en convulsion
totale mais cher Président on va pas
substituer une approche plus saine et
plus réaliste de nos relations et de nos
responsabilités par rapport à l'Afrique
de l'Ouest pour lui substituer une
responsabilité fabriqué par rapport à
une Afrique de l'Est où on a aucun
relais donc et comme vous venez de dire
qu'on éétait pas les sauveur du genre
humain et encore moins au Soudans
qu'ailleurs on va dire donc on en
revient au fait d'être disponible on est
un membre permanent du Conseil de
sécurité on est une armée remarquable et
si les pays en question demandent
quelque chose faut être disponible mais
là on va plutôt parler aux organisations
régionales africaines donc il faut
partir de la demande des Africains on
peut pas partir de notre sentiment à
nous de l'état de notre opinion même si
elle est horrifié il faut mettre fin des
politiques qui pour qui ont pour oiget
de calmer les souffrances des
téléspectateurs français en fait on est
obligé d'être dans un monde beaucoup
plus réel alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire en Éthiopie qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire voyez qu'est-ce qu'on a fait en
Somalie on peut pas faire grand-chose en
fait mais mais on entend oui mais je le
dis à regret mais on est quand même au
Conseil de sécurité il y a le système
onusien qui là quand même peut jouer un
rôle à la marge donc soyons disponible
mais on peut pas perorer
là-dessus on n pas le surtout vous avez
pris tout un paquet mais ce que je je
rouligne que il faut pas raisonner que
Afrique de l'Ouest il faut pas penser
qu'au trois ou quatre gouvernements
incapaes qui nous étilise non pas parce
qu'on est post coloniaux ça c'est du
vent mais parce qu'ils ont besoin d'un
Bou émissaire il y a il y a presque une
cinquantaine d'autres pays d'Afrique ça
remonte à longtemps déjà souousiteran
dans les sommets on disait à l'époque
France-Afrique on invitaé les pays
d'autres pays genre Angola et cetera
donc miteran chir ça fait très longtemps
qu'on a élargi et le président Macron a
renforcé cet aspect qui est initiative
par rapport au reste de l'Afrique alors
je sais pas s'il trouve pour autant des
correspondants à Paris au-delà des
discours des visites mais il y a
longtemps que les Français dirigeents
ont compris quand même qu'il y avait
autre chose que l'ancienne Afrique
francophone voilà donc je suis désolé je
réponds
pragmatiquement je vous remercie
infiniment Thomas tu prends le le merci
monsieur le Président alors nous avons
été saisis de neuf questions
complémentaires est-ce qu'on peut se
permettre de terminer l'audition à M 45
oui parce que historiquement vous av
vous aviez fait part d'un d'une
contrainte à 1230 donc je vous propose
mes chers collègues de poser des
questions de sur une durée d'environ une
minute qu'on va prendre de manière
groupée la parole est à Éléonore
carois merci merci monsieur le Président
eu alors dès 2017 le président de la
République a fait de la redéfinition de
notre relation avec l'Afrique une
priorité la refondte de ce rapport dont
les grands lignes ont été posées lors du
discours de wagadouu s'est structuré
autour de cinq grandes thématiques
engagement citoyen et démocratie
enseignement supérieur et recherche
entrepreneuriat innovation culture sport
et développement nous saluons la volonté
d'associer plus étroitement les secteurs
privés et les sociétés civiles qui
soutend également le renouveau du
partenariat avec la France et les autres
pays du continent africain dans ce sens
plusieurs programmes de l'Agence
française de développement comme les
initiatives digital Africa choose Africa
soutiennent les jeunes entrepreneurs
africains et les start-up monsieur le
ministre en 2013 vous avez dirigé un
rapport intitulé un partenariat pour
l'avenir 15 propositions pour une
nouvelle dynamique économique entre
l'Afrique et la France donc c'est un
rapport de référence sur la politique
française en Afrique considè z-vous que
la nouvelle dynamique insufflée par le
Président de la République depuis le
début de son mandat tienne compte des
propositions que vous aviez formulé et
je m'excuse de pas vous avoir saluer
initialement comme c'était une minute je
le fais maintenant merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui merci chers
collègues la parole est à Stéphanie
Galzi merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre la France a
toujours eu des liens importants avec le
continent africain du fait de notre
histoire commune je voudrais citer
Léopold seddar saingor la colonisation à
charrié de l'or et de la boue pourquoi
retenir la Bou et pas les pépites
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
prendre de perdre pardon notre attache
privilégiée avec l'Afrique notamment
avec les futures élites qui désertent
nos formations universitaires pour
privilégier celle anglo-saxon tout cela
par une politique francophone moins
volontaire aujourd'hui l'image de notre
pays s'est dégradée envers ses
dirigeants et également envers ses
populations par une politique illisible
de la France de collègues députés ont
remis en novembre dernier un rapport
sans concession sur les manques en
matière de diplomatie française 16
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
rassurer sur les différentes
possibilités pour établir une confiance
entre l'Afrique et la France la perte
d'influence politique entraînera une
perte de confiance économique et ce sont
les entreprises françaises qui vont en
subir les conséquences je vous
remercie merci la parole est à hercilia
souet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Vedrine novembre 2022 les
troupes françaises de l'opération Barcel
se retirent et une question subsiste
comment sommes-nous arrivés là dans ce
contexte notre perte d'expertise sur le
terrain fait grand bruit que pensez-vous
de la réforme du corps diplomatique
partagez-vous ces propos que l'on peut
lire dans le récent rapport
parlementaire
d'arnogal le ministère des Affaires
étrangères a subi dans le même temps une
concurrence accru de l'Élysée d'autres
ministères d'opérateurs tels que l'AFD
qui ont réduit son poids dans la
conduite de l'action extérieure dans les
régions où l'armée française est engagée
sur des théâtres d'opérations extérieur
les prérogatives du Cadoret tendent à se
réduire par rapport à celle du ministère
des armées du poids du président de la
République et de la cellule diplomatique
de
l'Élysée ne pensez-vous pas finalement
que l'expertise et les compétences
spécifiques des diplomates ne sont pas
perçu à leur juste valeur notamment pour
agir dans des régions du monde exposé à
la lutte contre les groupes
djihadistes merci la parole est à
Jean-Pierre
cubertffond le président monsieur le
ministre il y a quelques semaines nos
collègues Bruno fou et Michel Tabarot
présenter en commission des affaires
étrangères un projet de rapport sur les
relations entre la France et l'Afrique
en 175 pages on comprend que le rapport
expose un changement de paradigme la
présence française en Afrique est
aujourd'hui plus contestée que sur les
cante dernières années quand le
continent africain est lui-même traversé
par des mutations profondes nos
collègues soulignent l'importance et
l'urgence de repenser la stratégie
française pour l'Afrique et de mettre un
terme au déclin à la contestation que la
France subit notamment en Afrique de
l'Ouest un accent particulier est mis
sur le rapport à la communication et son
rôle essentiel dans notre relation avec
ce continent en partant du prisme
informationnel je souhaiterais ici vous
poser trois questions monsieur le
ministre considérez-vous que la
stratégie française actuelle en matière
de communication soit insuffisante quels
outils pourrai selon vous aider la
politique africaine française à l'heure
de la guerre informationnelle et
pensez-vous enfin que la montée du
sentiment anti-français en Afrique soit
inexorable je vous remercie merci
si la parole est à Lisiane
metteiller merci Monsieur les présidents
monsieur le ministre merci pour vos
propos passionnants sur la politique
africaine de la France et surtout pour
vos remarques préliminaires mettant en
lumière le problème de méconnaissance
entourant le processus de
décolonisation cette lacune de
connaissance effectivement peut
engentrer de l'incompréhension souvent
source de raccourci et si je vous le dis
c'est parce que je suis née en Afrique
j'y ai vécu et je ressens le poids de la
colonisation en France que je ne ressens
pas avec mes amis et partenaires
africains qu'il soient Ivoiriens
sénégalais nigériens congolais tout
d'abord j'aimerais évoquer deux points
de vue qui relient nos deux commissions
économiques et sécuritaires sur les deux
dernières décennies donc au cours de
cette période les exportations ont été
on une croissance remarquable doublant
au fil des années et parallèlement la
présence militaire française a été
sollicitée par plusieurs États africains
marquant un engagement significatif et
vous l'avez signalé dans vos propos
malgré des récents PCH dirigés sur
plusieurs normand qui ont contraint la
France à retirer leurs forces àamer à la
demande des États africains et c'est ces
ces évolutions souignent l'importance
des relations franco-africaine alors je
dois aller vite je voulais juste parler
d'évolution démographique et de la
projection du doublement d'ici 2050 et
du Règlement climatique j'en arrive à ma
question finalement j'aimerais
recueillir votre vision quant à
l'évolution future des relations entre
la France et les pays africains contenu
de cette évolution démographique et
économique et comment envisagez-vous la
relation avec la jeunesse Afric dont le
rôle croissant dans le paysage
socio-économique est indéniable je vous
remercie si la parole est à Vincent
Bru non si oui
allez-y merci monsieur le Président de
me donner la parole je voudrais rebondir
sur les propos que vous avveit tenu en
disant que il y avait une méconnaissance
de l'Afrique auprès de l'opinion
publique française et notamment des
médias euh le rapport de nos collègues
précité par euh par Jean-Pierre
cubertfon souligne la perte de
connaissance sur l'Afrique au sein même
du qué d'orsé euh une perte qui pourrait
peut-être s'expliquer en partie par la
fin du ministère de la Coopération en
1998 est-ce que à votre avis on peut
revenir à une meilleure connaissance de
la part des de nos diplomates sur ce
qu'estra véritablement l'Afrique et afin
de redonner une culture du continent
africain au sein même du kedoré je vous
remercie si la parole est à Mélanie
tomain merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre merci pour vos
propos je souhaite revenir à travers ma
question à la question épineuse de la
reprise des liens avec certains pays
d'Afrique poste coup d'État le Mali le
Burkina et le Niger il y a un mois Air
France a rétabli la liaison aérienne
entre l'aéroport charles- de Gaulle et
l'aéroport Modibo Keita de de Mamo en
dépit du maintien du classement du Mali
en zone rouge par le ministère des
Affaires étrangères une reprise des
liaisons aériennes avec le Burkina est
elle aussi envisagée alors que le pays
fait l'objet du même niveau d'alerte
d'après nos services diplomatiques ces
décision contraste fortement avec la
force des sanctions prononcées cet été
par la France à l'égard du Mali du
Burkina et du Niger en raison de leur
gouvernement pchiste quel lien réinventé
notamment économique la France peut et
doit-elle avoir selon vous dans la
configuration nouvelle que nous
appréhendons au Sahel cela me semble une
réflexion centrale concernant nos
partenariats économiques sur quel
support s'appuyer pour démontrer notre
bonne foi à agir en partenairire égaux
et non pas en Occident prosélite comme
vous l'avez suggéré tout à l'heure je
vous remercie merci il nous reste trois
questions et la parole est à Josie poeto
ah autant pour moi donc la parole est
directement à M
bamiti merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit tout
à l'heure j'attendre qu' les total
attention monsieur le
ministre non c'est ici vous nous avez
dit tout à l'heure les sociétés
africaines rêvent de vivre à
l'occidental je crois pas que ce soit
totalement vrai et et je crois que ce
qu'on constate dans la perte d'influence
des sociétés occidentales en Afrique
précisément c'est qu'il y a un rejet du
mode de vie occidental sur certains de
ces pans et notamment des évolutions
sociétales de nos sociétés occidentales
qui qui sont souhaitables je préfère le
signaler ici et comment alors que nous
constatons que les Russes les Chinois
sur des modèles traditionnalistes sur
des modèles autoritaires gagnent du
terrain comment en disant cela
euh on peut penser ne pas se tromper de
diagnostic et moi je souhaite que ns
ambassadeurs nos diplomates français
traitent le bon mal avec le bon remède
et je crois qu'il y a dans la perception
des sociétés africaines encore cette
vieille lecture que finalement notre
mode de vie est celui qui est souhaité
par les sociétés africaines je crois que
ce n'est plus vrai et je crois qu'il
faut analyser le ce fait là avec avec
réalisme voilà je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre vous souhaitez répondre
imm j'ai pas parlé spécialement des
Africains j'ai des classes moyennes de
ensemble des pays du Sud global veulent
vivre à l'occidental je pensais à
l'aspect concret en fait je pensais pas
aux valeurs je pensz pas à la conception
de la famille ou du couple voyz donc on
peut distinguer le social et le sociétal
et c'était pas centré que sur l'Afrique
c'était pour distinguer le rejet de
l'Occident rhétorique politique et
cetera et puis les gens veulent vivre
mieux que les enfants à l'école que la
justice fonctionne normalement chacun a
une bagnole et une maison voyez c'est ça
que je voulais dire pour le reste je je
comprends ce que vous dites et enfin
pour une dernière question la parole est
à Olivier
fort merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre je vais être très
court puisquon a qu'une minute et puis
j'apprécie comme beaucoup
ici votre regard réaliste sur sur les
affaires du monde mais je voudrais
profiter de votre présence et de votre
influence pour dire aussi une chose
simple c'est que la France sonore quand
elle tient sa parole et donc je voudrais
profiter de votre présence pour dire
qu'il y a aujourd'hui une situation sur
les les auxiliaires de l'armée française
en Afghanistan qui sont aujourd'hui
menacés de renvoi en Afghanistan ils ils
nous ont aidé au moment où nous luttions
contre les talibans ils sont aujourd'hui
donc menacés et ça tout ça dépend en
fait de visa qu'on leur remette et donc
j'aurais aimé que vous puissiez avec
nous appeler à ce que ces auxiliaires
militaires puissent être effectivement
euh obtenir leur visa pour venir en
France et donc être protégé parce que si
on veut garder une influence dans le
monde il faut que la France on sa propre
parole aussi voilà et Monsieur le
Ministre une dernière question c'est ça
de la part de
euh madame amelet madame amelet on peut
prendre la dernière question et ensuite
vous faites une réponse madame amelet
vous avez la parole monsieur prés je
vous remercie monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre tout d'abord tous
mes remerciements pour ces échanges très
intéressants que nous avons ce matin h
il se trouve que je suis rentrée hier
matin du Cameroun donc c'est pour ça
aussi que je voulais absolument poser ma
question euh il y a quelque chose que
vous avez dit dès le début de votre
intervention qui me paraît extrêmement
important c'est que en France il manque
de personnes qui connaissent l'Afrique
vous avez raison c'est une constatation
euh non seulement personne en France ne
la connaît mais en plus il y a un défaut
euh également que nous avons c'est de
pas suffisamment nous appuyer à mon avis
sur nos ambassadeurs je vais vous donner
un petit exemple euh le Cameroun est
classé zone orange euh ce qui ce qui
blesse fortement euh les Camerounais
parce que quelque part on leur dit que
le pays dangereux et l'ambassade depuis
plusieurs années c'est de faire remonter
l'information pour changer ça pour que
que les Français puissent aller plus
facilement au Cameroun et vice-versa
donc ça c'est un premier problème les
ambassades ne sont pas écouté et alors
ça leur paraît et peut-être que c'est
aussi l'origine de ce problème que nous
avons ce problème d'image c'est que les
Camerounais se disent on classe nos pays
dangereux et quand on regarde France 24
et qu'on voit ce qui se passe en France
avec les attentats et cetera c'est ils
ne comprennent pas qu'on est de de poids
de mesure comme ça donc j'ai encore
quelques minutes monsieur le Président
par ailleurs vous disiez tout à l'heure
alors on a un problème de déficit
d'image là-bas mais on a des on a aussi
il faut le savoir juste ça parce que
c'est quand même important nous avons eu
l'occasion de rencontrer beaucoup d'élus
au Cameroun et les élus là-bas que ce
soit les élus régionaux les maires sont
de très grande qualité eux connaissent
très bien leur sujet ils savent
exactement ce dont ils ont besoin donc
vous parliez tout à l'heure vous disiez
il faut être à l'écoute vous avez raison
ils savent exactement ce dont don ils
ont besoin écoutonsles c'est dommage
j'avais plein de choses à vous dire
aussi sur le sentiment antifrançais vous
aviez vous avez dit tout à l'heure qu'il
n'existait pas si il est bien réel je
peux vous l'assurer
malheureusement il est pas tellement
dans l'élite mais dans la population il
y a un réel sentiment que nous ont orté
les Français qui vivent là-bas de plus
en plus ils sont victimes de ce
sentiment antifrançais donc il faut
faire quelque chose de façon urgente je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre et
monsieur le Président merci monsie merci
chers collègue monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole alors je vais pas tout
reprendre il y a trop de questions sur
trop de sujets le Cameroun on a entendu
le témoignage mais c'est pas une
question direct je continue à penser que
le sentiment antifrançais fait partie
d'un d'un sentiment antioccidental
global qui est attisé organisé
artificiel et qui n'est pas durable et
que on peut y répondre de 1000 façons
bon la question de Monsieur fort
monsieur for je suis absolument d'accord
avec vous quand j'ai parlé du
détournement du droit d'asile sur lequel
je suis très documenté c'est pas du tout
en
fait non c'est bien c'est moi je très
bien le business dans l'ensemble de
l'Afrique et ailleurs qui rapporte plus
d'argent que la drogue maintenant pour
fabriquer des fausses filières avec des
faux fausses expertises des faux
témoignages et C et C bon ça n rien là
c'est vraiment un cas typique qui relève
de la protection je comprends même pas
qu'il a une hésitation parce qu' s'il y
a des gens qui sont je rappelle que le
droit d'asile n'a pas été conçu dans les
conventions international pour pour
faciliter l'immigration économique c'est
pour protéger des gens en danger pour de
vrais pour des raisons de race de sexe
de religion de politique de guerre et
cetera on est typiquement dans ce cas
donc là je comprends pas vous avez
raison moi je m'associ je sais pas sous
quelle forme suassoci à votre démarche
aucun lien effectivement avec ce que
vous aviez dit précédemment mais
simplement parce qu'il y a des cas
aujourd'hui de gens qui étaient aux dans
l'armée française en Afghanistan qui
sont aujourd'hui à téran et qu'on
renvoie vers l'Afghanistan on les
renvoie à la mort parce qu'on sait très
bien ce qui va leur arriver et donc
c'était juste pourtir l'attention pour
que l'intérieur veuille bien délivrer
ses visas et faire en sorte que les
choses avancent c'est aussi simple que
ça il y a quelques cas qui sont
actuellement euh donc en suspens voilà
en tout cas moi je suis prê machchier à
quoi que ce soit là-dessus c'est évident
qu'on peut pas les les renvoyer à la
mort les gens qui ont eu le courage de
se mettre de notre côté est-ce qu'on
avait raison d' être c'est un autre
sujet ça mais c'est pas c'est pas de
leur faute c'est pas de leur faute he
bon euh écoutez je vais un peu répéter
je pense que la euh
il faut avoir une analyse réaliste de la
situation mais pas pas des féties pas
désespérés encore une fois pas
masochiste ça sert à
rien mais équilibré je crois qu'il y a
des forces variées en Afrique il y a des
forces de rejet de l'Occident
globalement qui vont fonctionner ou pas
qui comportte avec un attrait en même
temps dans certains domaines mais pas
dans tous ils peuvent être penser que
nos sociétés sont dégénérées tout en
voulant vivre pareil il y a des zones
particulières le Cameroun a toujours été
assez
s'est remonté pour des raisons
historiques de division du pays et ce
bon c'est variable mais je ne pense moi
je m'inscris pas dans l'idée qu'il a une
sorte de déferlement du sentiment
antifrançais d'autant que ceux qui le
gèrent n'ont aucune solution à rien et
que l'étape suivante c'est qu'ils sont
eux mêmes rejetés par ceux qu' ont
excité pour rejeter les bouqu émissaires
de service ils ont pas de solution les
Russes n'ont pas de solution les Chinois
ont des solution ponctuelle ils pose pas
de conditions démocratiques mais après
ils tiennent les pays dans un engrenage
d'endettement et et cetera donc ça reste
assez ouvert à mon avis assez instable
et si la France retrouve confiance en
elle si elle a une approche on a dit
tous à peu près quel que sois les les
groupes politiques d' une approche qui
est moins moins porante qui est moins
dominante moins paternaliste aussi bon
qui est simplement disponible
pragmatique dans les partenariats cela
dit ça commencé depuis très longtemps je
a cité le Cameroun qui est un cas on
pourrait parler de l'Algérie qui est un
cas compliqué mais c'était pas dans
notre champ il y a plein pays d'Afrique
o la question ne se pose pas ne se pose
pas parce qu'ils n'en a pas besoin parce
qu'ils se débrouillent plutôt bien ils
ont pas besoin d'inventer tout ça des
pays dans lesquels les diaspor
africaines en France n'ont pas besoin
d'activer ce sentiment là j'en ai parlé
plusieurs candidats à la présidence du
Sénégal qui disent on est très gêné par
le type de de réseau de propagande mise
en avant par les les Sénégalais de Paris
de Paris pour d'autres raisons bon c'est
vrai que c'est très compliqué mais même
avec toutes les influences même l'action
des Russes l'action des Chinois et les
15 puissances dans le monde qui ont des
politiques en Afrique le Brésil l'Inde
les Abou dhabiens les cataris les
Israéliens les COV tout ce qu'on veut
tout le Japon même là je crois qu'on a
beaucoup d'atout beaucoup d'atout que
l'histoire afrique- France est peut-être
très cruelle à certains moments mais
magnifique à d'autres mais qu'il faut
réinvestir réinvestir humainement avant
même de réinvestir financièrement
financièrement les sees entreprises ont
pas besoin de de comme nous pour savoir
ce qui est rentable ou pas bon mais r
invvestir humainement alors ça ça veut
dire ça rejoint la francophonie ça
rejoint les études ça rejoint les bourse
et alors là on est en compétition avec
un système global dans le cadre de
l'amerriicano globalisation et donc
c'est vrai qu'on est un peu paralysé par
notre propre incohérence incohérence ce
qui donne certaines évolutions
françaises qui vont trop loin dans ce
sens donc il faut que faudrait que les
Français retrouvent un peu de confiance
raisonnable en n-même sans rebasculer
dans la
prétention alors c'est très plein de bon
sens ce que je dis mais c'est pas du
tout laadn français donc c'est la limite
par rapport à ça mais il faut voz je
parle pas du tout d'un point de vue
surtout après vous avoir entendu hein je
pessimiste quant au professionnalisme
diplomatique je l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises quel que soit le nom de
l'institution le nom de la formation le
nom de l'école il faut le
reconstituer alors on peut nommer c'est
très bien de d'ouvrir mais le corps
diplomatique était très ouvert en fait
avant donc c'est très bien d'ouvrir
d'échanger on peut nommer des gens dans
des postes d'ambassadeurs bilatéraux ça
c'est une chose on peut tester des gens
qui viennent d'autres carrières mais
dans les métiers de négociation non on
pas s'improviser on est dans un monde
j'ai pariné un L qui va paraître en
janvier où on parle de l'avenir des
négociateur on est dans un mondeù il a
des négociations très compliquées tout
le temps très compliqué genre
intelligence artifici iiciel genre les
les vaccins genre et cetera les les
questions nucléaires d'avenir bon mais
c'est un métier c'est pas lié à la
spécialité la négociation est un métier
un métier comprendre savoir ce que l'on
veut savoir sur quoi on peut accepter un
compromis ou pas comprendre ce que veut
l'adversaire ou le négociateur où est-ce
qu'on va l'amener un compromis c'est un
vrai métier ça ça se prend pas comme ça
donc l'idée qu'on puisse gérer des
carrières
des fonctions publiques dans qui n'ont
rien à voir avec ça puis brusquement on
est propulsé là ça c'est pas une bonne
idée donc je l'ai dit je reviens parce
que ça a été redit par plusieurs des
interventions finales il y a il y a un
métier à respecter à reconstituer et
c'est pas joué pour le moment dans l'INP
on dit pas l'inverse mais certains
disent les drag des ministères vont
pouvoir gérer des carrières son engager
à tro quatre postes de distance et les
gens qui ont inspiré ça disent non pas
question il y pas question que les gens
prétendent faire des la même carrière
dans le même métier régulièrement si
celle cas on aa vraiment une une perte
de capacité dans la négociation qu'il
faudra corriger encore
après je le reprends parce que c'est un
point qui est apparu quel que soit
l'origine politique en fait des
intervenants et c'est très très très
utile beaucoup être sensible à ce
discours et donc il faut qu'on soit très
disponible par rapport à l'Afrique de
demain qu'on les assomme pas de scénario
de politique d'annonce de tout notre n
stratégie là euh ils se demanderont si
on est disponible et on est pour faire
quoi on verra ça dépend des cas il y a
des tas de domaines et on a plein plein
d'atouts et je le répète la le
commentaire des chefs d'État sur on veut
pas rester en tête à tête avec la Chine
il y a aucun dirigeant en Afrique sauf
des pchistes tenus par les les Russes
dans un moment aigu ils sont pas
nombreux qui voudront se passer de la
France ça existe pas
quel que soit le degré d'excitation
fabriqué ou pas des populations contre
la France donc il y a on a énormément de
cartes à jouer si on accepte de se faire
violence nous-même en étant un peu
différent de ce que l'on
est traditionnellement VO alors si c'est
naturellement c'est compliqué à
corriger vous voyez donc c'est une forme
d'optimisme que je développe devant
vous voilà cher président merci voilà
bon non je voulais simplement remercier
le le ministre pour cette audition à la
fois passionnante et et positive et
remercier le le président bourlange et
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
pour ce travail commun qui j'espère
ouvrira un nouvel air de collaboration
entre nos deux commissions et monsieur
le Président je vous cède désormais la
parole juste dire un mot très très bref
je crois que vous avez dit monsieur le
ministre que vous étiez moins pessimiste
après nous avoir entendu j'espère que
nous nous sommes plus réalistes après
vous avoir auditionné et si c'est le cas
nous n'avons pas perdu notre patinée
voilà exactement